[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it's another beautiful day you guys
would you like to go to Whittier well
that sounds like an awesome idea let's
go see if there's any fishing to be had
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it did you wanna play one keep your rod
up buddy you got it whoo there you go
okay you got him yeah good job done
whoa-ho good job look at the teeth on
this guy
there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
you got awesome get it done get up get
it you got it he's trapped get up get up
and bring it back in yep
grab him grab his hands grab the seal
I love you
[Music]
there you go in ancient Athens right
here
[Music]
all the huge feet wow that is a huge sin
Nathan do you want to catch another fish
okay
my wet little boy hey you guys got
really wet are you warm well guys we're
doing something fun as a family we are
going to the Alaska Zoo it is a fun
little zoo it's got a polar bear some
puffins all sorts of fun little stuff
the kids will have a great time and it
is a great way to get out and enjoy
ourselves on a slightly rainy day what
does the polar bear do that seal is
making Blowfish on the glass hey you
know what the Fox says
they're sleeping I'm going deaf
[Music]
hey Tommy was that Papa's employ very
cool Oh keep your head down
well the Nichols family is going to
Seward my whole family my parents and my
brothers and sisters and their spouses
we're all gonna meet down in Seward
tomorrow morning and we're gonna go on a
fishing charter for halibut rockfish
snapper it's gonna be awesome and it's a
really great chance for the whole family
to get together and do something fun
together and we're also going to cook up
some fresh halibut and it's gonna be
great you guys excited to go fishing for
big fish
well here we are at Summit Lake Lodge
we're gonna stop and get some food so
you guys hungry Nathan needs pants those
sexy legs can't go out in public
look at this thing got onions tomatoes
bacon eggs ham cheese the garbage
grinder it's a classic
[Music]
they're trans this one cable or wire
rope with commercial bandsaw playing
carpeted and you know velasca coral this
one's Alaskan coral and bandsaw blades
and cable also what's the first piece
off the head
well we're here in Seward a little bit
earlier than we needed to be and I just
saw somebody reeling in some salmon down
here so I'm gonna take out my Nash scope
carp rod which was not designed for lure
fishing and I'm gonna do some fish in
here now this is the ocean I'm at its
Resurrection Bay behind me
this is saltwater and in Alaska you can
snag in the saltwater
and I speak soon
oh yeah this is not a salmon you want to
eat this is a stocked
salmon they stock them right here at the
mouth of this stream but there's nowhere
for them to go back to spawn so they
just hang out here in the ocean with
nowhere to go
they just end up dying right out here in
the ocean but no good to eat
there we go
and there's salmon are in it's that easy
at all fairness well I saw probably 15
pink salmon landed here and I caught two
but they're all really close to spawned
out no good for eating so I'm gonna call
it go get warmed up and dry and a good
night's rest for tomorrow Oh Nathan
Oh dad has the coldest hands in the
world while I was out catching spawned
out pink salmon my wife here the
beautiful artist was painting all you
painted daddy and me Barbies are daddy
of you
[Music]
[Music]
well it's 5:00 in the morning and I've
been awake for the last two hours
because my sister and my youngest child
snore like Lumberjacks and we're all
sharing a room
so it's 5:00 and there's a cafe that
should be open down the street probably
go get some food
that fritter is the size of my child's
head that thing's huge go fishing all
right Nathan you ready to go fishing
yeah there we go well I am super excited
here we are getting ready to go on the
sorceress with puffin charters we're
gonna be fishing all day for halibut and
rockfish and hopefully we are going to
pack the cooler I got my my family here
got my brothers and sisters my mom and
dad Tom Ian and Nathan and Becca so
we're gonna we got a full boat and it's
gonna be a real fun trip
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're halibut fishes so I'm
just waiting for this to go tap it that
tap or to buckle over we're fishing on
slightly over 300 feet of water though
it's deep and we've got a bit of a gale
coming at 2 o'clock so we got to catch
your fish and get out of here Jenner you
take it easy Tommy even though we're
excited we gotta take it easy so you
don't crash and hurt yourself
bang
while the waves are turning out to be a
little bit much making it hard to fish
and right now we've got two people
throwing up and a few others who are
looking a little green around the gills
so we're gonna move a little bit inshore
and see if we can't get a little bit
calmer water and have a little bit
better chance of catching something and
standing up while we catch something you
know what we call throwing up on a boat
we call that feeding the puffins
defeat the pocket
poor Becca she is so seasick she barfs
so hard over the side she lost her
glasses
eating breakfast in front of all the
sick and afflicted isn't appreciated so
I'm gonna eat out here
yeah I know it's not ready
you'll executive down your glasses got
to say it got one right there you see
the air bladder comes out because you
bring them up from 220 feet yeah
biggie gasps Tommy hey buddy
oh there's your right here Tommy get
Lilly there go okay there you go
okay here just go okay little buddy
that is awesome
oh look at that beauty man this is gonna
make a great play right there they call
this chicken Facebook exploding fist
bump there is a different one this has
been an absolute blast we've got tons of
these dusty rockfish and we're kind of -
a love it but really the halibut axe
we're looking for another spot we can't
get it just a big gallon
I've been wanting to eat this thing all
morning but
so seasick and they don't want me to eat
it in front of them
[Music]
there's the belt go to above the
mountains
can you see him
okay we are fishing in a new spot in
five hundred and forty feet of water
it's just going and going and going is
deep water I love it right here folks
all right you got like what 20 feet down
five hundred to go I'll come back in
like 15 minutes million check on you
sure I can do that if you like yes
that's a Pacific card right that's a big
boy that's huge
nice card Becca
[Music]
yeah good job Melanie oh that is heavy
okay oh oh you got one
that's awesome grace I'll come back in
about 50 minutes and check in on you
okay
yeah nice higher we get a relevant
relevant relevant relevant which is good
job Becca it's a good-looking fish yeah
my mom's got another decent halibut here
last time I went halibut fishing with
her she caught what a 95 pounder was it
hundred fifty all congratulations
there's a nice fish thank you nice
Pacific cod man
nasty cheese oh yeah odd or is it on the
list they're reelin saralyn you got it
buddy keep going you got dude
there you go Tommy hey Tommy you like
your first halibut was that fun oh good
job buddy
we need a bunk up don't we Tommy that's
a big one that's good eats like a
lobster look at see we have limited out
and we are going to call it and there is
a storm coming so it's not a moment too
late so we're gonna reel in it go and
clean some fish and we've seen a lot of
salmon jumping and even a few circling
the boat like shark so as we head back
to seward we're gonna troll for salmon
and see what we can get there's lots of
Pink's around but hopefully we can get a
silver to
you almost have
the shot
[Music]
[Music]
that's the good stuff right there and
the look-see lice on them just when you
want to dive right
yeah that was awesome we picked up a
bonus silver salmon had a couple on then
great time but all good things to us
come to an end and it's time to go clean
some fish
[Music]
here's where they weigh all the fish so
at the end of the day everyone brings
back there yeah it's take the pictures
real big stuff they throw up on the
scale
like 270 pound halibut and salmon shark
that is the salmon shark they got a gut
um right soon as I catch him otherwise
the meat goes bad so it's relatively
great white look at that sucker
say hi Nate
oh is that mommy's shirt no need no
touchy
- man down
and slippery down there anybody well
guys we had a great time we caught loads
of fish we did let the weather get us
down our crew was awesome and we had a
great time with puffy charters and
caught as you can see I'll load a fish
so we're bringing home a ton of fillets
right
yeah yeah
alright guys I want to wheel this over
to the car well we had a great time here
in Seward my back is killing me my right
arm is dead we have a cooler full of
fish and it's time to go home take a hot
shower and cook up some fresh Alaskan
halibut
you like it bigger very much you like it
Tommy so it's our last full day in
Alaska we are going to go get some
breakfast we're gonna go run some
errands and then we're gonna get to see
a bunch of family and do a big family
picnic and we're gonna try to make the
most of our last day here in Alaska I
have a little over 20 nieces and nephews
so when my boys get together with their
cousins it is a battle royale these kids
play rough so my sister bought a bunch
of these inflatable bumper balls and
just turn the kids loose at this family
picnic
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
child Cagefighting one of the favorite
spectator sports of the Nichols family
bad what a great two weeks this has been
absolutely awesome it's been so good to
see family go do some fishing and get
back to Alaska but it's time to go home
and it's gonna be a long flight home
we're leaving at 2:00 in the morning 60
pounds of fish we're gonna miss ya
there it is better
what an amazing trip we had a great time
and had so many wonderful adventures
these memories will last forever
don't forget to check out parts 1 2 & 3
of our Alaskan adventure and check the
video description for links to some of
the places who visited on this trip if
you liked this video don't forget to
check out our other great videos from
the outdoor boys YouTube channel and
don't forget to click Subscribe we put
out new videos every week and check out
my other YouTube channel the catfish and
carp youtube channel for great fishing
videos thanks for watching